>> Stephen: WE ARE UNDERWAY 2-
CENTERED IN FRONT
DUCHENE, SOFT BACKHAND PASS OUT
1-0, NASHVILLE.THE SPECIAL TEAM
THEY TRY TO LIMIT HIS
DUCHENE COULD NOT GET ANYTHING
WITH THAT LOOSE CHANGE. CTED IN
TWO ONTO BATTLE BEHIND THE NET
AND ZUCCARELLO GOT DDLETON GOT
SHOT A MARC-ANDRE
FLEURY, A MASSIVE SAFE
AND THE GAME IS ALL EVEN, RYAN
SCORE!
AND IT IS 2-1, PREDATORS.
THEY GAVE UP A GOAL ON A MISCUE
ON A BAD PASS AND IT IS
SPURGEON.
ALL THE WAY ACROSS TO
ZUCCARELLO.
HE GOES  3-1,
PREDATORS.
OF THAT IS JUJUREBOU
SAROS CAME OUT HAD THE ANGLE
CR
KAPRIZOV GOT HIS OWN REBOUND
AND MAKES IT A 4-2 GAME  IN THE
BIG BLOCK SHOU TIP IN FRONT,SAR
EVERY TIME KAPRIZOV HAS THE AN
RYAN JOHANSEN!INSTEAD
EVERYBODY UNDERSTOOD